CHRIS BROADFOOT: I
think we're live.
LUKE MAHE: Welcome.
Hello, and welcome to another
Maps API Hangout.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yep.
So today, we'll be doing some
interview with Jason Sanford,
who you can see down in the
bottom, down there.
So a quick introduction.
I'm Chris.
I work on the Google Maps API
Developer Relations Team.
LUKE MAHE: And I'm Luke.
I also work on the Maps API
team down here in Sydney.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And
Jason, do you want
to introduce yourself?
JASON SANFORD: Yeah, sure.
I'm a web developer
at MapMyFitness.
So we've been using the Google
Maps API for quite a few years
now, so a pretty big
customer, I think.
So been doing lots of fun stuff
lately, converting some
apps over from v2 to v3.
So we'll chat about
that a bit today.
LUKE MAHE: Cool.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
So Jason, let's just get a bit
of background on what you've
been working on.
So could you give us a little
bit of history, what you're
interested in, sort of
your background?
Do you have a GIS background?
JASON SANFORD: Right.
So I've been in the geo business
for maybe six, seven,
eight years now.
Worked in local government
for a while.
Then went over to work in the
private sector at Ubisense,
doing some real-time location
work as well as building web
mapping applications for a lot
of electric utilities using
Google Maps API, as well as
lots of other crazy tools.
So that was a lot of fun.
And just a few months ago, I
joined the MapMyFitness team.
I've been helping out with our
new route engine, which uses
the Google Maps API
extensively.
So that's been a fun project.
But to be completely honest,
I've only done a very small
percentage of the work with
this route engine.
I've jumped in a few places
where I was needed, but I've
got a co-worker that's done
a lot more of the work.
But I know a lot of
what's happening.
Not much of the credit
goes to me for this.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
So can you--
I mean, you've only been
there for a few months.
But can you maybe give some
insight on why they chose to
use the Google Maps API?
JASON SANFORD: So the Maps API
for us is pretty important.
So a lot of the reason we
use it is because of the
directions.
So it's much easier to map a
route from here to 10 miles
away if you can just click two
points instead of clicking 20,
30 points along the way.
So you can click a point at your
start, click a point at
your destination, and then
manipulate the route along the
way as you see fit.
But usually with the directions
service, you
generally get the route
you want on the first
try, which is huge.
It's a big time-saver
for our users.
Street View is also a pretty
big enhancement, mostly for
the directions and the pretty
good quality maps.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
Yeah, I was checking out
your new routing stuff.
It's pretty slick, nicely
customized as well.
Although I didn't see
where you guys are
using Street View.
Can you talk about that?
JASON SANFORD: You know, we
haven't used it much.
I guess we're essentially just
using the standard Street View
control that comes with the Maps
API, so the peg man drag
and drop on the map.
Just the standard use there.
So coming from v2, I'm
not sure if we have
that ability or not.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
And so you talked a bit about
going from v2 to v3.
Do you want to just tell us
about that experience?
Was that an enjoyable one?
JASON SANFORD: Yes.
Yes and no.
So it is great.
The API is much better.
It's very well-organized.
But our tools are pretty--
I want to say complex,
but they're not.
Just these one-off things we're
doing, they're fairly
complex things on
the back end.
So my co-worker Matt, who is
responsible for building most
of this, he spent a good
while working on it.
And it was kind of a necessary
thing to do,
since v2 is out soon.
I'm not sure how soon, but the
clock was ticking, so it was
time to make the leap.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, so I
think [INTERPOSING VOICES].
Yeah, I think-- so there's a
three-year deprecation policy.
And I think that three years
is up in May next year.
JASON SANFORD: Right.
LUKE MAHE: So if you haven't
started moving across, you
really ought to now.
JASON SANFORD: Right.
So that was a pretty big
project, but it's been good.
It's been well worth it.
So we released our site today,
with some pretty
good reviews so far.
So people are excited.
LUKE MAHE: Awesome.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
I saw there was a bit
of buzz going around.
That's great.
JASON SANFORD: Yeah,
a little bit.
Enough buzz to make us sweat
for a few hours.
But it was good.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: That's a
great problem to have.
JASON SANFORD: Right.
LUKE MAHE: Until your server
catches on fire.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
JASON SANFORD: Right.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
So do you want to give a
bit of a demo of the--
so you ported the existing map
from v2 to v3, but you've also
released this new routing
engine that
has additional features.
Is that right?
JASON SANFORD: That's
right, yeah.
So we're using lots of cool new
things, like the bicycle
layer and using cycling
directions, and adding a few
other custom layers that you
guys have released recently.
So, yeah, I can give a demo.
That works.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
JASON SANFORD: It's my first
Hangout here, so I'm not sure
exactly how to switch screens.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So I think
if you go in the top left,
there's a Screen Share button.
JASON SANFORD: Gotcha, OK.
And I pick Desktop or
Google Hangouts.
Let's choose this.
So how's that?
Do you see yourself?
LUKE MAHE: Inception.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
very Inception-like.
JASON SANFORD: All right.
And so now you see our
homepage up there?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
JASON SANFORD: OK.
So this is kind of the whole
redesign of the site.
Not really here to talk
about that, but we've
changed lots of things.
And while we switched this, we
figured it was time to release
our new route engine, which
we've got here.
So the first thing you see is
that we customized the map
based on what site you're at.
So MapMyFitness has a
number of websites.
MapMyRide.
As you can see, I'm out here.
So on this site, we turn the
bicycle layers on by default.
You can turn those
off if you want.
And if you visit any of the
other sites, like MapMyWalk,
or MapMyHike, MapMyTri, all of
our other websites, those are
turned off, because a lot
of people just aren't
interested in those.
So we'll turn them
back on here.
So you can see it defaulted to
my location, where I'm at now.
So if I wanted to start mapping
a route, I could just
click right there.
And I could just start clicking
my way around to
figure out where I wanted to
go, or where I did go.
But I'll undo those changes.
Because one of the great things
we can do is just have
your start location, and then
come up here to the Search
bar, and just type
in any address.
So this was a park I went
to the other day.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So is that the
Elevation API down there?
JASON SANFORD: Yeah, so that's
the Elevation API as well.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
JASON SANFORD: I'll show you
that in just a second.
So my second point is that part
that I just clicked on.
So now we can just kind
of see our whole
route that we generated.
As you can see here, it jumped
quite a ways over to this nice
bike path, which is
pretty handy.
You wouldn't want to go up any
of these other semi-major
roads if you've got these nice
bike paths over here.
But what you might want to do
also is just take this route
and drag it over to a slightly
different bike path.
So we're using Google's
draggable directions for that.
We can add any points along
here, and drag them wherever
we see fit.
If you notice at the bottom,
the elevation should be
updating as the route
is updating.
And as you mouse over the
elevation, you'll see that
location on the route, and get
a very specific elevation in
the chart down there.
LUKE MAHE: That's nice.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
What do you--
JASON SANFORD: So we can--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh
sorry, go on.
JASON SANFORD: No, go ahead.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh.
So what are you guys using
for the chart down below?
JASON SANFORD: Highcharts,
which is a paid but very
affordable JavaScript
charting API.
So it uses SVG, unless you're
in IE, and then it does that
crazy VML stuff.
But yeah, it's worked
really well.
I see it a lot around
the internet.
As I've implemented this, I've
looked around, and lots of
people were using that, so
it's pretty powerful.
So maybe you've mapped that
route, and you want to come
back to where you started.
We've got this handy Double
Back button that will just
kind of take you out to
where you are, and
then all the way back.
And then you get your total
mileage set to 13.74 miles,
and you're back at
your start here.
And then from there, you
could save your route.
It also saves these directions
that you can change.
You can just say whatever, and
that'll change that cue note.
So if you wanted to print these
directions, your custom
notes here would print
out as well.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: That's cool.
JASON SANFORD: Yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: A nice
little touch.
LUKE MAHE: Could I go and send
these directions off to my
Garmin device, or something
like that?
JASON SANFORD: So we do
allow export of GPX.
I don't think those--
I'm almost positive those
directions are
not included in that.
So something sort of like that
that we do is, if you say you
are going to do this workout,
you can check Send to Phone
here, and if you're logged in,
and you have our app on your
phone, it will send that route
to your phone, and draw it on
the map, so you can follow it as
you're riding, or running,
or whatever.
LUKE MAHE: Can you also share
the route with friends?
JASON SANFORD: Right.
Yeah, so you can make this route
public, and so anybody
with a link can see it.
Or you can have your MapMyRide
or MapMyRun friends see it.
But what most people typically
do is make it completely
public, and then post it to
Facebook, or Twitter, or
whatever social network
they're into.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
JASON SANFORD: But yeah,
you can definitely
send this to whoever.
LUKE MAHE: So what were some of
the biggest challenges you
think you ran into when you
were building this?
JASON SANFORD: One of the bigger
challenges was today.
So we released this, and we love
these bicycle directions.
What we didn't realize until we
released it today is that
the bicycle directions
may not be available
outside of the US.
So that was a lot
of our fault.
We didn't do, apparently,
enough
debugging in other areas.
So that's something we can work
around for, for sure.
Most of the difficulties were
not really Maps API-related,
but your typical web development
problems, working
around different browser
bugs and whatnot.
So yeah.
LUKE MAHE: The joys of being
a web developer.
JASON SANFORD: Right
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Well, we do a
lot of work to ensure that the
Maps API works on many
different browsers.
We've got a lot of automated
testing, so we have all of our
tests running continuously
on the many,
many different browsers.
LUKE MAHE: And devices.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Many mobile
browsers, yeah.
JASON SANFORD: Cool.
LUKE MAHE: It's very impressive
to see, a wall of
phones all running tests.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
JASON SANFORD: Yeah,
that would be cool.
So yeah, that's pretty much my
demo that I was able to pull
together in two or
three minutes.
There's lots of other cool
things you can do.
We show these distance
markers here.
You can enable and disable
those, and change the interval
you show those on.
Turn the bicycle paths off.
We've implemented the
weather layer.
So if you want to see how the
weather is going to be if
you're about to run out the door
and go for a ride or a
run, you can see that maybe
there's this storm coming, you
shouldn't go right now.
So yeah, having lots of
fun with the Maps API.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
especially because you can put
cloud cover on those
maps [INAUDIBLE].
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
JASON SANFORD: I thought
we had traffic here.
Maybe I just don't see it.
But anyway--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: What
else can you do?
Do you guys use Styled
Maps at all?
JASON SANFORD: You
know, we don't.
We've thought about that,
just to maybe cater them
to each of our sites.
So each of our sites has a sort
of specific style, mostly
just color-based.
A lot of our runners--
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, you could do it
so if it's running, pop up
some other paths, and get
rid of roads that are
not going to be used.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Or in
bicycling, you're done with
the bicycling layer.
But maybe if you're walking,
you can expose some of the
paths through parks, or
something like that.
JASON SANFORD: Yeah, exactly.
That's a good idea.
We hadn't thought about that.
So yeah, lots to do there.
So this is really just
our first iteration.
It's gotten lots of
good feedback.
Lots of things to change,
maybe, but it's
been a lot of fun.
LUKE MAHE: Kind of what
we like to hear.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
LUKE MAHE: Well, thanks
for that.
JASON SANFORD: Yeah,
no worries.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
So outside of MapMyFitness,
have you got anything else
you've been working on?
I saw you had a-- was it a
vector layer for the Maps API
a while ago?
JASON SANFORD: Yeah, that
was a lot of fun.
So I'm not sure if I'm still
screen sharing or not, but--
LUKE MAHE: You are.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yeah, you are.
JASON SANFORD: So this is
essentially just a library
that lets you add lots of other
vendor-based web GIS
stuff on top of Google Maps.
So if you're an ArcGIS Server
user, or a CartoDB user,
Arcturus, lots of other
providers, we've got a few
others planned as well.
So it just lets you easily add
in these layers on the ArcGIS
Server, just throw them right
on top of Google Maps with
some semi-customizable
infowindows.
I guess this one down
here uses--
well, that's not
what I wanted.
This one here uses Google Chart
APIs, and lets you just
do lot of crazy symbology
and whatnot.
So it's been a few months
since I worked on this
project, so I don't remember
too, too much about some
specifics here.
But it was a lot of fun.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So on the
ArcGIS side, was there much
work there?
Because I think there's an
existing utility library.
Do you use any of that?
JASON SANFORD: No.
This was built basically--
at my previous job, we had the
need to just pull in data from
all these different services.
Some of it may be live, and some
of it may be just like,
give me all the data in this
one service or layer.
So this is built on the notion
that you can load live data or
just some static data, just
give it to me and show it.
A few of these are semi-live,
so as you pan the map here,
you'll get more features.
Obviously, you don't want to
load every county in the
United States in one load, so
these only load the individual
bounding dots.
So as you pan the map, you
get more features.
So yeah, lots of different
options.
Lots of decent documentation, I
think, of things you can do,
like styling infowindows, or
styling actual features,
controlling the scale
range, and whatnot.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, that
documentation looks good, actually.
I want to steal that template.
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
CHRIS BROADFOOT: That's
Twitter Bootstrap.
JASON SANFORD: It is, yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Is that
a JSDoc output?
JASON SANFORD: No, I
don't like that.
I like code and documentation
separate, but that's just a
personal thing.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
JASON SANFORD: But yeah,
this is the deal.
Not so recent version of
Twitter Bootstrap.
It's really good for people like
me that aren't super good
with design.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, it makes
everything look beautiful.
LUKE MAHE: It does.
It's nice.
They've got a lot of the
basics done right.
You can just use them all.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I hope it
doesn't get too over-used.
I quite like it.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
LUKE MAHE: Cool.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So we might go
through some news, look at
some cool maps that
have come out.
Have a look at Airbnb and the
Made in New York map that came
out recently.
And then just go through some
stack overflow questions.
So let's go through it.
I'll just start presenting
here.
So first bit of news,
we have renamed--
LUKE MAHE: Google--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh yeah,
so-- you go ahead.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, we've renamed
Google Earth Builder.
Now it's called Google
Maps Engine.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
I'll just pull up the
blog post for that.
LUKE MAHE: You should have
started where it was a window.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
I should have organized this.
LUKE MAHE: I spent a while
playing with that today.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
Yep, so it's just a rename.
Oh yeah, and there's also the
launch of the Google Maps
Engine grants program.
So if you're a nonprofit, and
you want to use what was
previously Google Earth Builder,
you can now apply for
a grant to get access
to this new product.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Very cool.
So what else?
Oh yeah, so came across this
great library last week called
Overlapping Marker Spiderfier.
LUKE MAHE: Oh yeah,
I saw that.
That's pretty cool.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Sort of a new
way to solve the too many
markers problem.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, it was an
interesting approach to
clustering.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
LUKE MAHE: We've tried
this many a time.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So we mentioned
it, I think, three
times at our last Hangout that
Luke and I wrote an article on
too many markers, so what
happens when you
have too many markers.
How do you solve it?
And these guys have
re-implemented the sort of
spiderfication that you
find in Google Earth.
So let's just have a quick
look at their demo.
OK, so when you click on a group
of markers, they sort of
expand and fan out so you can
see each individual one.
And it's kind of cool.
A little white line shows you
where the marker was precisely
on the map, and you can click
each individual marker.
LUKE MAHE: So this is an
interesting approach where the
user doesn't really care about
how many markers are there,
just that there's a bunch
there for some reason.
So when you click on them,
you can show them
all at the same time.
So it's pretty cool.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So that's over on GitHub,
Overlapping Marker Spiderfier.
LUKE MAHE: He would have tried
that so many times.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
So what else?
You got any show
and tell, Luke?
LUKE MAHE: Not really today.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
LUKE MAHE: I've shown
everything.
Do you want to show a couple
map of the weeks?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So this week's map is Airbnb.
So if you're not following our
developer blog, go over and
subscribe in your favorite
RSS reader.
It's googlegeodevelop
ers.blogspot.com.
So this week's map of
the week is Airbnb.
And these guys just really kick
ass at user interface.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, it's really
nice where it isn't just
showing what's in data, and
just works really cool.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So let's
go and have a look.
So I think you can now--
LUKE MAHE: Actually, I was on
this site the other day
looking for--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Let's
pretend like we're
going on holiday together.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, let's.
Where do you want to go?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Let's
go to New York.
LUKE MAHE: OK.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, wow.
My internet's really slow.
OK, where am I going?
New York.
Cool, nice autocomplete there.
What else?
When do we want to go?
Let's go tomorrow.
LUKE MAHE: All right.
I'm sure our boss will
let us have time off.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So once we do our search,
we can go over here.
We can get the list view.
Wow, that's pretty cheap,
$81 a night.
JASON SANFORD: You'd better
grab that fast.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
We can go over and look
at the map instead.
So I was actually looking
for a place to stay
in New York, and--
LUKE MAHE: Not with me?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Not with you.
I'm sorry, Luke.
LUKE MAHE: Aw.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, and a map
would have been great to--
because apparently I don't
want to stay in some
parts of New York.
LUKE MAHE: I've heard that.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Apparently.
Apparently.
Oh, so these guys have
solved the too many
markers problem as well.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, so this is
similar to the marker cluster
where they're just putting a
marker with a number that says
how many are there.
And then as you zoom in,
they're basically just
re-querying and splitting
up that number.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So
what happens?
So where do I want to stay?
I think we want to
stay way up here.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, let's stay
in that Meatpacker area.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Meatpacker,
all right.
Let's--
LUKE MAHE: And the office is
over there to the left.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Putting--
oh, OK.
Well, that's interesting.
I was expecting to click on that
marker, and it shows me--
it would be cool if it did that
spiderfication, or zoomed
in or something,
but it didn't.
$230.
OK, that seems expensive.
LUKE MAHE: That's in
Australian dollars.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
But yeah, this is pretty cool.
So we've got some sidebar
here on the right, so I
can filter by price.
Maybe I just want to
say I won't spend
any more than $100.
Wow, lots of results.
And where do I want to stay?
I want to stay in Harlem.
This is what my friend
told me.
LUKE MAHE: All right.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
Great.
LUKE MAHE: It would be
a bit of a commute.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And yeah,
what do I want?
I want a kitchen.
Cool.
So what happens now?
Do I go over--
LUKE MAHE: It would be cool if
they hooked this up with the
Places API, so you could see
kind of what's around.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, like a
Walk Score kind of thing.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
that would be cool.
So we've got this little map
up here in the right.
It's pretty cool.
Nice.
OK, great.
So that's--
LUKE MAHE: And do you
want to show the
other map of the week?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh,
do you have any
comments on their site--
LUKE MAHE: I do not.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
For the review?
It's pretty good.
LUKE MAHE: It is pretty good.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's going--
I wonder if they have
Street View--
LUKE MAHE: My only comments
are the buttons on the top
right don't match the buttons
on the front page.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Ah.
LUKE MAHE: But that's OK.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, yeah,
so they've got some
Street View up here.
That's a great idea.
So we can sort of explore
the area.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Marilyn's
famous.
Cool.
Well, these guys are using an
old version of the API.
LUKE MAHE: It doesn't
have the pancake.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, no--
so in the Maps API 3.8,
we added Click to
Go, which means that--
say I'm on maps.google.com.
If you click anywhere inside the
panorama, you'll be zoomed
off to that different
panorama.
LUKE MAHE: And if you click
on the wall, it'll zoom
and face the wall.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yep.
So it looks like these guys are
also animating through the
panorama to just sort of
give you a look around.
One suggestion here.
It would be really cool to just
put a marker on where the
place actually is.
So if you put a marker in Street
View, it'll sort of sit
in its place and move around as
the panorama moves around.
Yeah, that's my only
suggestion here.
Yeah, that's quite nice.
Oh, cool.
So they might be using the
Places API here to just sort
of show you what's around.
LUKE MAHE: That's cool.
I like that.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
that's nice.
LUKE MAHE: And I'd say oh,
they're giving you a rough
idea of where it is, because
they don't want to show you--
that's why they're not putting
a marker in Street View.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, right.
They don't give you
the address.
LUKE MAHE: For privacy
reasons.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Ah.
LUKE MAHE: Smart of them.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
So I understand.
Well, maybe Street View doesn't
make so much sense,
because you don't actually
know where it is.
Somewhere around here.
Cool.
Nice.
OK, what's next?
So--
LUKE MAHE: The other
map of the week.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: The other
map of the week was--
LUKE MAHE: The Made
in New York.
Which was using the
marker cluster.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, so let's
take a look at that.
So I heard on extremely poor
authority that Mayor Bloomberg
actually coded this himself.
LUKE MAHE: Well, given
how easy the
marker cluster is, sure.
I quite like the UI.
It works quite well with kind
of the [INAUDIBLE].
So I feel it's pretty nice.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Let's start.
LUKE MAHE: There's lots of tech
companies in New York hiring.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
Cool.
So this is using the marker
cluster, which Luke designed.
Actually, the thing I like about
this site is that they
didn't space the clusters
too far apart.
They've sort of brought them
in together so they sort of
sit next to each other.
LUKE MAHE: It sort of gives a
heat mappish sort of feel.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
It's sort of a bit more
interesting, sort of makes it
look a bit more dynamic.
And they're actually using a
really nice star map here.
So we'll have a look
at that in a sec.
But it looks like they've
simplified the roads, made
them white.
It just looks really nice.
So as we click here,
we zoom in, and we
can see all of these--
what are they?
Oh, they're hiring companies.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, and so you
can filter on the right.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So I can filter
digital companies, and
then select individual
ones with this nice--
LUKE MAHE: Game Changer.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
it's really nice.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So it looks
like they're using--
what is it?
LUKE MAHE: Fonts API?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, Fonts
API or CSS3 fonts.
It looks nice.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, well done.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's great.
LUKE MAHE: It solves
a problem.
It's nicely done.
It works well.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So let's have a little bit
of a look at the code.
LUKE MAHE: Because that's
what you want.
You want everyone looking
at your code live.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So we'll just pull
up the HTML.
We can sort of see how they've
structured this.
Let's see some things that
they've done well, maybe give
some recommendations.
Oh, come on.
OK, we can look through the--
LUKE MAHE: Look through
the JavaScript?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, god.
OK, my laptop's a bit--
LUKE MAHE: There we go.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, I'm
not even up there.
LUKE MAHE: Oh, you're
projecting--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh
yeah, there we go.
LUKE MAHE: There we go.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
So the first thing I see is they
haven't compiled their
JavaScript or [? identified ?]
it.
So immediate speedup there.
LUKE MAHE: Just on download
time and caching--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, but it's
great, because we can
just have a look through.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, because if
this was all As and Bs, it
would be quite difficult
to read.
But you can see the
first bit there.
They've got their style map.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So the great thing about
JavaScript and just the web is
you can just look through
people's code.
So I really like this map style,
so I can go through
their code, have a look
at what they've done.
So you can see they've made
all the roads white.
What have they done here?
They've sort of lightened the
road labels, re-colored the
water, and turned off
transit lines.
LUKE MAHE: So if you like this
style, you can borrow it?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, so--
LUKE MAHE: And change it?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, so
they didn't actually use
simplified.
They just made it all white.
LUKE MAHE: Looks good.
And they used jQuery.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So
that doesn't look
like map-related stuff.
So we've got a fair bit of
customization on the map here.
That looks great.
So the other thing we can see
here is they're using one
infowindow for the whole page.
LUKE MAHE: Which is brilliant.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yep.
So as I click on multiple--
as I click on them and then go
over here and click on another
one, we're not opening up
multiple infowindows.
We're just re-using the
one infowindow.
Yeah, what else?
All right, so yeah, you
can see how they're
using marker clusterer.
So they've got a bit of
customization here on the
click event.
LUKE MAHE: Yep.
So basically when you're
clicking on the marker
cluster, they are hiding the
infowindow, hiding the details.
And if they're zoomed out too
far, they're going to--
I can't read the bottom
part of that.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: If
it's zoomed too
far out, then they--
LUKE MAHE: And they're
populating
the list on the right.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, right.
Oh, so this is cool.
So say we're zoomed-- there's
two companies that are really,
really close to each other,
maybe in the same building,
and I click on them.
It just tells me there's
two companies here.
So this is another great
solution to too many markers.
If they're in the exact same
position, you could do the
spiderfication, or you could
just open the infowindow and
say what's underneath.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
Because the marker cluster has
a nice thing where you can
[? listen to ?] click events.
So when you click on a cluster,
they'll tell you how
many markers are actually in
that cluster, and all the
markers that are in the--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
Cool.
So a whole bunch
of other stuff.
Have a look through if you're
interested in it.
So let's just take a quick
look at their HTML.
Looks like they're using--
LUKE MAHE: Some nice ASCII
art at the start.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
that's great.
Yes, so they've done a great
optimization, which is just
putting all the JavaScript
at the end of the page.
Which means it loads after the
rest of the contents there.
Oh, and they're using a Maps
API key, so they can track
their usage.
Definitely recommend that if
you're using the Maps API.
So they're loading jQuery from
the Google AJAX libraries.
LUKE MAHE: And nicely you can
see here is when they're
loading up the source tag,
they're just doing slash
slash, which means if they're on
HTTP or HTTPS, it will just
use the correct protocol,
and you won't get
mixed content warnings.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, it's
good practice to be in.
LUKE MAHE: One caveat is, if
you're loading something just
off file, file colon slash
slash, it won't work.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So loading off the AJAX
libraries that use Google's
content delivery network, so
you'll probably get a speed
up, and chances are
your users will
already have jQuery cached.
So that's great.
LUKE MAHE: OK, those were
maps of the week.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool, yeah.
So--
LUKE MAHE: Go to
some questions?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, let's
go to some questions.
So we didn't really have any
on our Google Moderator.
I'm a bit sad about that.
Yeah, so we didn't really have
any on our Google Moderator.
So we're just going to go
through some stack overflow
questions that we thought were
interesting, or weren't
already answered.
LUKE MAHE: And then those
playing at home can go and
answer the questions before
we get a chance
to, and get the points.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, I'm not going to go in
and put the answer in.
LUKE MAHE: You have
to [INAUDIBLE] to
go watch our Hangout.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
Just post a link to the video.
So this first one is how to
tell KmlLayer about your
custom map projection.
So this is an interesting one.
So it looks like he's got a
custom map projection for some
[? Russian ?] tiles, and he
also uses the default
projection.
But when he uses KmlLayer, it
doesn't work, obviously, with
the custom projection.
So, unfortunately, KmlLayer
renders the tile server-side.
So if you're using some funky
projection, there's not really
any way that we can get that
over to our server to move the
markers around.
LUKE MAHE: Going to have to
convert your stuff to Mercator
projection.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So either go and try to get
tiles that are in Mercator
projection, or I think the
easiest thing in this case
would be to use geoxml3, which
will bring down your KML file,
parse it, and go and
add markers to the
map as regular markers.
LUKE MAHE: Which is fine
as long as your KML
file is not too big.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
Yeah, either that, or you
could probably fake it.
If you're only showing a KML
layer, you could sort of
pretend that--
do some funky projection.
I don't know.
It's probably possible, but
geoxml3 is the easy way.
Cool.
So next one is how to bind
an infowindow as a
property of a marker.
So we don't really do
this very much.
LUKE MAHE: And binding is kind
of an overloaded word here,
because we've got the concept
of [? MDC ?] where you
actually do bind.
So are they kind of thinking
like, I've got a marker, and I
want to set a property which
is a reference to my
infowindow?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
I'm not sure.
LUKE MAHE: Technically you can
do that in JavaScript, because
you can add properties
to any object.
You want to be careful that
you're not using a property
that already exists, or that
we may use one day.
So naming the property something
like underscore
underscore, some prefix,
underscore infowindows 38
equals my infowindow.
And then when you have a click
event on the marker, you can
just go to this dot underscore
underscore infowindow 38.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
LUKE MAHE: And there's
your reference.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So if you actually want to bind
them together, you can
bind the map property.
But you've got to be careful
to unbind that if you ever
want to open that infowindow
on a different marker.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
Otherwise, they'll all be bound
together, basically.
LUKE MAHE: Or you can bind their
position together as
well, if you just want them
moving positions.
So if you've got a marker and
you're dragging it, you want
the infowindow to follow.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
But I see here there's also a
similar question, how do I
clean up an infowindow when the
associated marker is hidden?
I think there's a great
answer down here.
Or maybe not.
I mean, this looks
pretty similar.
So basically, you want to listen
to the map changed
event on the marker, and then
do something based on that.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, visible
change is probably
not the right one.
Map change is a better option.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
LUKE MAHE: Because when you
remove a marker, you set map
change to be null.
And so you could do--
it really depends on your use
case, but you may do something
where do I have a variable
that says the
infowindow is open?
And if it is, then hide it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
LUKE MAHE: And this may trick
you when you've got multiple
markers, and one hides, and
you're not really sure.
So it really depends on your
setup, and what you're
actually trying to achieve.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
Yeah, perhaps if you're using
one infowindow, you could set
a property on the infowindow
that points to a marker that
was last opened.
And then when you're deleting
markers, go and check to see
if those two are equal.
And if they are, then you
close the infowindow,
something like that.
Yeah?
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
So there's one more here.
Well, actually we've
got two more.
So animated lines with arrows
between two coordinates.
So we actually did something
similar to this in one of our
slide decks.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, we had us
flying from Sydney to Perth.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So if we go over to the
documentation, there's some
really useful utility functions
for spherical geometry.
So if you know the
two points--
so if you just go and search
for a spherical, what you
probably want to use
is interpolate.
So your From Lat Long is
wherever you're going from.
Your To Lat Long is wherever
you're going to.
And then you can call this
function as you're animating,
and keep updating fraction,
which is the third parameter.
And then that returns a Lat
Long, and you could then use
that to update a polyline
or move a marker from
the From to the To.
Yeah.
LUKE MAHE: Bonus points if you
do it in an animation frame.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
LUKE MAHE: Then you get
nice performance.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So in terms of arrows, at the
moment, we don't have any
arrows on polylines.
But there's an open feature
request for that.
LUKE MAHE: So star that,
and we'll let you
know if it gets done.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
You could probably fake it with
a little marker as an
arrow, and move that.
LUKE MAHE: And then kind of
rotate it, and see if there's
still something if you
wanted to try and
get the bearing correctly.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
Yeah, or an overlay view.
LUKE MAHE: Mmm.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: If someone
wants to create an overlay
view that just has an arrowhead
that can be rotated,
that would be pretty cool.
LUKE MAHE: Do that in
Canvas as well.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, lots
of cool ways.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK, so
draw a polygon from
user-entered vertices.
OK, so he's got a list of
coordinates, and just
wants to draw them.
So the first thing you've got to
do is get these coordinates
into an array of Lat Longs,
which is the format that we
use to draw polygons.
So if you actually have it in a
text field like that, you'd
probably want to maybe split
on commas, and for every
second one, you can get the
Lat Long pair out of it.
LUKE MAHE: And then with that
array, you can then create a
new polyline object.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Polyline, yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LUKE MAHE: And then add that to
your map with that array,
and you've got a line.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
But if you haven't seen it
already, you should take a
look at the drawing editable
polylines, which lets your
users go and draw polylines
on the map, and polygons.
Cool.
So that's it.
LUKE MAHE: OK, I think that's
it for us today.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Jason,
are you still there?
Looks very dark.
JASON SANFORD: Yeah, I turned
off for a second.
Didn't want to look
too sleepy here.
It's getting late here.
LUKE MAHE: Well, thank you
very much for joining us.
JASON SANFORD: Yeah, it's
good to be here.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
Great, that's it.
Thanks for watching, those
who are out there.
Jason, thanks very much
for coming along.
JASON SANFORD: You're welcome.
It was fun.
All right, see you guys.
LUKE MAHE: See you later.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: See you guys.